elle te plaît beaucoup aux mélodies t'a
plu tout de suite alors c'est pas
qu'elle m'a plu tout de suite je les
trouvais classe distinguer le jour j
voilà une bonne est magnifique après je
pense qu'on était d'accord pour dire
qu'on n'était pas le style l'un et de
l'autre
c'est ça voilà elle s'attendait pas à ce
que je sois je fasse la même taille quel
bas que j'ai pas voilà s'attendait à
quelqu'un qui ait les yeux sombres qui
soit ténébreux voilà c'était pas jeter
pachoud etienne hébreu pour boîte et
ténébreux pour moi aussi mais trop mou
et donc ouais donc toi qu'on sent qu'il
ya quelque chose mais c'est vrai que
c'est le principe du truc vous
connaissez pas mais on a l'impression
que c'est bien parti
mine de rien au départ on se dit bon il
va se passer quelque chose peut-être que
c'est le caractère de mélodies elle est
comme ça et puis tu a tout tenté pour
essayer de rapprocher de mélodies même
une petite séance de massage et j'ai
l'impression que j'ai l'impression que
tu as plus tendue que détendue
je crois que pour elle massé les mains
c'est comme si je ne sais tout pas
géopolis on va saluer vous aimez je sais
que lui pense un rapprochement physique
éventuelles et pour moi c'est pas
naturel
ça fait paul à rien
arrêtez de parler pour quel est ton nom
c'est une bonne idée ben voilà au final
ce massage il est autant mal à l'escale
je pense et donc c'est une déception que
ce sens bien ridicule voilà j'espère que
son comportement elle sa rencontre parce
que je souffre un peu
mais franchement franchement elle est
pas du tout sympathique dès le début non
mais vous vous êtes super sympa vous
d'essayer des choses et là y'a rien par
rapport au casting banon mais si si elle
qui fait pas investies mais oui mais la
meuf après voilà on va en parler dans un
stade adrien là qu'est ce que tu te dis
là tu sens que ça va être une galère
cette affaire ben je me dis que c'est un
peu comme gilles je me fais tech
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je te dis la vérité
après un mois voilà je vais pas je vais
pas jeter la pierre à vélo dit tu vas
nous dire ce qui s'est passé parce que
après t'as craqué beaucoup de
téléspectateurs ont été choqués par la
séquence du dîner alors c'est vrai ou là
ça a été très violent il quand je te
vois voilà aujourd'hui parce que je le
vois tu vois tu te sers met en garde moi
j'aurais été mort
un jeu qui ferait tomber sur un mec
comme ça je sens que c'est un mec tu
vois crème voilà c'est une crème tu vois
je te jure que c'est vrai je le vois
tout de suite et c'est vrai que là ça a
été ça a été dur pour toi il ya
énormément de téléspectateurs qui ont
été choqués par cette séquence regarde
comment s'annonce la nuit selon toi ça
va être impeccable
[Musique]
dans la nuit s'annonce tu avais des
doutes là dessus bah ouais bah voilà
comment tu nous imaginions chez nous
imagine pas je sais pas vraiment à
entendre le sourire tu veux toujours
poussé la boue mais bien sûr parce que
tu vois que je met les formes et qu'il
te préserver par rapport à certaines
choses d'accord tu présenteras pas quoi
par rapport au fait que t'es dur tu me
fous mur sur mur fou surtout je prends
j'encaisse je dis rien
hier dans les accepte pas oui j'accepte
deux premiers procès est maintenant et
je te comprends et signe c'est normal il
c'est normal ça arrive est apprivoisé
monf est fait il faut que dalle aux
loisirs à moi que je pas sincère
m
je pense ça brise lames est donc adrien
quand on voit ça franchement moi ça me
touche beaucoup fait pour vous chez vous
il ya énormément de réactions sur les
réseaux sociaux
j'aimerais d'abord au camp interroge
adrien là à quel moment vous êtes sans
vous avez dit vous êtes dit ça y est
c'est mort entre nous non à aucun moment
parce que parce que j'avais toujours
espoir et vous étiez mariella alors ils
étaient donc là vous avez divorcé cia
n'ont toujours mariée en fait là il va
se passer encore plein d'autres choses
c'est que le début de l'aventuré
ouais d'accord mais ça a été un moment
très très difficile il faut savoir que
c'est le début mais nous dit a été très
sur la retenue a été très dur moi je le
comprenais pas forcément je m'étais
engagé dans cette aventure en disant je
vais trouver la femme de ma vie je vais
trouver quelqu'un comme moi aussi
peut-être tombé amoureux des gestes non
non non non non pas sur l'instant en
tout cas mais hélas hélas on vous êtes
comment les bains je peux pas je peux
pas le dire mais en tout cas on le verra
par la suite mais en tout cas il va y
avoir pas mal de rebondissements
derrière c'est donc en fait c'est un
titre exactement oui oui raymond bayle
c'est quoi la vraie personne de cette
fille de cette femme c'est parce que moi
j'ai l'impression que c'est une fille
qui est venu juste pour date pour faire
de la télé elle est bonne mais là pour
se marier avec toi non ici c'est la prod
qui lui ai dit après maintenant ça va
pas parce que c'est le bordel il faut
que turow fasse machine arrière et que
tu te mettes ali mais moi je vais avoir
du mal à rentrer dans le délire j'espère
que dans quinze jours j'avoue humblement
non merci
[Applaudissements]
si je suis très franche du son et on
nous a pas demandé de jouer un rôle ou
quoi que ce soit de nature elle même
elle même elle puisque quand tout ce qui
se passait devant les caméras il se
passe exactement la même chose en off
l'histoire des massages ça bien sûr que
hors caméra j'essaie de la détente jeudi
au bras tant il ya pas les caméras à 10
ans se détend vous l'avait embrassée
aubin pas ce moment là vous l'avez vous
l'avez déjà embrassé quand même je sais
pas le prêt à dire oui avec une galoche
calloc'h langue de boeuf gueulant que
l'on dirait que l'on pas que l'on règle
en êtes-vous il ya un pas que l'on juste
un smack
on se moque de kellogg's ici certaines
assez des charges précis grâce entre
autre irait tout mais il s'est passé des
choses
voilà peut-être qu'il s'est passé des
choses derrière il sur le cou à ces
vérités non mais le mystère du couple
c'est vous quand même c'est pas elle
parce que 99% des hommes au troisième
studio mal à faire ces barges c'est
l'humiliation thorax qu'est ce que vous
espérez que j'espère vous espérer un
miracle
non mais je pense que avec la patience
aujourd'hui elle avait elle a vécu
peut-être des histoires difficiles au
préalable aupravant et elle se méfier
des hommes tout simplement il fallait
que je lui montre que bien sûr que ce
n'était pas se répéter dans le contexte
du mariage j'aurais arrêté tout à la
voile à elle son mari 11 avril à vous en
mêler ma famille là c'est votre alliance
l'avouer mais il est marié ou que je
m'étais faut arrêter
[Rires]
ani le marié c'est pour ça et c'est pour
ça que je me suis je me suis un peu
investi quoi valérie c'est d'ailleurs
pour cette raison qu'on ne la comprend
pas elle dans cet épisode là en tout cas
parce qu'on se dit elle fait une
démarche
elle va dans un mois moi je que je ne
comprends pas personnellement mais c'est
vraiment un petit personnel elle fait de
démarches pourquoi à ce moment là opposé
un mur aussi dur aussi froid aussi
distant à quelqu'un dont elle dit a
priori et bas j'y vais je vais tenter un
truc dans ces cas là laisse toi un peu
hâlé et tentent l'aventuré et on ne
comprend pas du coup c'est pour cela
qu'on comprend pas cet épisode un peu
compassé en tête comme ça je veux pas
jouer les filles faciles gens méritants
pardon à lesparre les roues alors ça n'a
aucun rapport c'est bon c'est pas la
production alors donc jouer un rôle tout
va bien que cette jeune femme allait
coincer
elle a un passif et moi je soutiens de
rien mais faut pas en faire une [ __ ]
c'est pas ça du tout
face à kaunas tout se passe bien sûr
at-elle encore dit cette jeune femme
elle est coincée manifestement l'un des
problèmes psychologiques assez sérieux
du fait qu'elle aime pas être touchée
est manifestement oxyde de compatibilité
ça va ce match et maintenant la vie
c'est le coup match et elle l a pas fait
la bille ont roulé tabanou donner des
concerts où la tentation rouge ou noir
super bateau de dressage un what you pay
là c'est pourquoi adrien qu'est ce qui
pousse un garçon beau comme vous abbott
la manifestion conseiller financier à
faire tilt aventure qu'on dise que tout
le monde nous dit elle tant ce mec là
c'est un beau gosse et bien il faut pas
trouvé de meuf
alors tu vas nous répondre dans un
instant rien donc on rappelle pour ceux
qui nous rejoignent
il s'est marié dans mario premier regard
mario premier regard premier regard on
se voit vim
on se marie c'est le contraire de la vie
normale alors tous les gens se disent
sur twitter sur les réseaux sociaux
adrien beau gosse musclé jeux verts
bleus
sympa enfin je dis voilà 30 par an pour
voilà un conseiller financier sympa je
le sens je te sens que chacun mette bien
en plus je vois tout de suite on l'aimé
bien toi ici pour dire il n'ya pas que
ça ne m'a pas maxime voix et et c'est
vrai que vous dites pourquoi participer
à cette aventure n'avait pas trouvé une
meuf ah bon si j'en avais trouvés mais
après c'est un levier supplémentaire en
activant sur internet
moi juste derrière ni té et non en fait
je croyais tout simplement je me dis on
va te présenter la fille qui de faux
bond à juste d'être marié ouais bon et
j'ai vraiment cru en cette expérience
alors il ya plein de gens qui ont été
choquées par là c'est quand qu'on vient
de voir
me voilà où mélodie te fracasser août
est en pleurs est ce qu'aujourd'hui tu
en mesure de me dire que mélody et toi
ça va mieux alors oui ça va mieux ça va
beaucoup mieux d'accord je vois que tu
as encore la bague
oui ça va mieux ok tu en train de nous
dire que vous êtes encore ensemble
non je suis pas en train de dire ça donc
tu regrettes nous dire que vous n'êtes
plus incertaine
ça va être en dvd de devenir m6
allez je veux pas le football alors moi
je vais être désagréable comme
d'habitude en fait moi je suis 100%
incompatible avec cette émission et je
trouve que adrien vous qui êtes
tellement sympathique tellement pratique
il faut avoir beaucoup de succès je
comprends à travers ça pourquoi j'aime
pas cette émission parce qu'en fait en
fait le mariage est une sorte de gadget
en fait c'est une supercherie dire qu'on
s'amusait à l'aventuré un début
d'aventuré une fin d'aventuré on sait
pas hantise en fait moi je suis super
mal à l'aise avec ça et je vois tu
reçois aurait dit aussi vous fait ouais
mais je suis complètement les avis et
pas dans cette émission l'arrêt de 16
ans l'attend du colonel fabien conte
feuilleton fait le mariage mais en fait
le mariage ça ne doit pas être
feuilletonner ça c'est pas une télé
réalité aller aux anges aller aux
marseillais mais ne vous mariez à ce
moment là c'est trop ça crée alors ils
répondent à sanofi aussi sont
intelligents non mais après il faut
forcément faut qu'ils aient des
tracteurs si tout le monde comprenait il
se retrouvait là dedans personnes
regardent aurais tu regrettes non pas du
tout pas du tout maintenant il faut que
l'aventuré c'est une aventure atypique
je le referais web 2010 squatté par an
j'ai eu ma mère au téléphone juste avant
elle m'a dit attention à ce que tu dis
alors je suis un gros bisou à votre
maman comme matériel elisabeth élise
avec lui fait un gros bisou à la mode
pape a aussi calé après norbert très
sympa aussi voilà et alors il encaisse
alors du coup mon père l'a forcément mal
pris au départ voilà il a pris ça un peu
bas il a eu le même rêve a gagné là tu
respectes pas le mariage l'institution
voilà donc il a fallu lui expliquer que
moi je voyais des choses un peu
différemment on va vous les voyez
justement ces spots nom qui fait que ça
n'a pas été un frein pour vous dire ben
je vais mettre ma famille dans une sorte
d'histoire est improbable
normalement c'est quelque chose qu'on
prépare en famille voilà on l'a mariée
elle amène sa mère pour essayer sa robe
et là tout d'un coup ça en devient un
phénomène à une sorte de phénomène de
cirque qu il fait que pour vous ça n'a
pas été un frein après il faut avoir un
regard je trouve objectif sur le mariage
aujourd'hui le mariage c'est plus ce que
c'était il ya beaucoup de mariages qui
castrés ne pensez pas sacré
vino a sacralisé du tout non voilà c'est
notre vision des choses
moi je lave comme une autre c'est prêt
c'est une étape comme une autre journée
au salon du livre
adrien pas un compliment juste on va pas
on va pas on va libérer
adrien est ce qu'aujourd'hui tu es
heureux très heureux très heureux très
très beau tout va bien pour moi je vois
bien tu as l'air heureux parce qu'on m'a
dit quand même que tu qui fait bien
caroline ithurbide oui mais je kiffe
aussi qu'il faut c'est isabelle isabelle
le casino adrian en tout cas moi ce que
je peux souhaiter c'est énormément de
bonheur
oui ce soit avec mélodie ou sans mélodie
est en tout cas si c'est avec mélodie ça
me fait plaisir parce que c'est vrai que
je me sens quand même je te sens
accroché je te sens je te sens pas du
tout ne l'est pas et ne seraient pas le
nouveau mec on va pas alors mélodies
at-elle été trop dur envers nos noms à
10% merci adrien avoir égalé